four key takeaways from and always
entertaining 2022 fantasy season first
of all gotta give credit where credit is
due to our top overall qb1 rb1 wide
receiver one and Titan one Patrick
Mahomes Austin Eckler Justin Jefferson
and Travis Kelsey take about especially
Travis Kelsey six PPR points per game
better next closest tight end pretty
pretty pretty good also how about this
being the year of the quarterback go
back and look at every single season NFL
history and you will see three of the
top 14 highest scoring fantasy seasons
of all time all happen in the year 2022
thanks to Patrick Mahomes Jalen hurts
and Josh Allen Kingston Kings of course
also our abilities to predict injuries
continue to largely suck Christian
McCaffrey and Derrick Henry the poster
boys for the injury prone label largely
got through the entire season intact
meanwhile young studs seemingly guys
that would be incapable of getting hurt
John and Taylor priest Hall Devonte
Williams unfortunately missed far too
much time to be happy with and finally
wide receivers changing teams continues
to not be all that big of a deal AJ
Brown Tyree kill Devante Adams all got
traded and guess what just like Stefan
did just like DeAndre Hopkins ended up
arguably being even better in their new
situation just goes to show you that
when a wide receiver is that talented
doesn't really matter who's throwing up
the ball